okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about incremental
improvements to often language and we've
got a number of topics today let's start
off with Association transpose yeah so
this question has appears a number of
times probably the fact that it keeps
appearing means tells us the answer I
think I think that very fact I mean I
needed to use this other people have
needed to use this the the reason we
don't want transpose to just do this is
what well the fact that it might break
things because it has worked this way
for so long but it's not done anything
with associations right it's it's a bit
because no true race yeah III think we
shouldn't I think we should have a
separate Association transpose exactly
for the reason that we can do things
like introduce missing objects and so on
right we have several examples where we
specialize Association functions we
should do the same here I think so and I
think we need Association transpose it's
come us to come up at least a dozen
times
um okay so then what what is needed here
we need to in this case where there
under full associations right what is
the I mean don't we already have this in
some of the joiner cross type
functionality this question of how we
add things in I mean this seems to me to
be a less obscure version of things like
um um you know some of these join a
cross type things yes what does
Association thread do again
well it's like taking two lists and
creation oh yeah right
so association thread is closely related
to I see I see so association thread
right in a sense it's transposing rules
and least right right okay
yeah this association transpose the
function we need we should just have it
are there any other issues about it
there's a question of a few add what is
it doing is it doing a key union of all
of these of the keys in all of these
different associations what order does
it use if this is ABC and this one is BA
what does it do first so what it does is
it's it's doing a if we've got a
sequence of things and thing number
seven or something has they're all ABC
subsets but then there's a D later on it
is the first it is the what is that what
is the rule then does it does it scan I
mean I think the rule could be that it
basically is scanning lexically so it
goes through all the things on the first
item then it goes through the things in
the second item skipping the ones it's
already seen it's like it's a delete
duplicates of the join of all of those
key sequences that make sense yes um
yeah so in particular that also includes
their previous case in which we have the
same keys but in a different order so we
just return things as the first
Association
sorry that the same keys in a different
order yes the previous question so
transpose right now requires that the
same keys are given in the same order I
think I see with an allowed heads thing
yeah we should ignore that it shouldn't
care it should just use but now there
probably should be a mechanism to
specify the keys that you want to get
out so in other words Association
transpose could have a second argument
which is the target keys so I'm saying
all of those things and then it could be
a list of keys you want to get out in
the order you want to get them out so
that it drops anything that is not
consistent with those keys I guess we
don't I guess it can be something where
we can say key take or key drop around
this now what does this do if it isn't
just a list of associations if it's
something more complicated like an
association of lists I think with any
combinations of associations and lists
probably lists of lists yeah fair enough
but so then what is it doing so it's got
the same level specifications as
transpose is that correct well let's
think about it whether it's possible I
mean I think it's always possible by
filling them as missings
because that Deer Agra Phi's it so what
happens if we have two associations with
completely different keys
in the Association transpose well then
it's got a lot of missings in it well
hold them well what would actually
happen so the transpose will be a single
Association wait a minute what what is
the transpose here so why isn't it just
a bunch of missings
and why doesn't it make lists that are
always pairs yeah but they have a bunch
of missings in them yes I was thinking
that when we have a deeper rugged case
it may be frequent that the
association's inside are very different
we just had missing Stan well the only
thing we could do other than missings
and this is kind of a join of cross
option right if I'm not mistaken is to
just leave it out of the list do you see
what I'm saying well I mean so we could
have a list that was one two missing
three four missing right but one thing
we can do is to treat the missing like a
nothing and have that drop you see what
I'm saying so the list does not maintain
its index position correctly but the
list simply maintains the bucket of
what's in it correctly well I don't know
how we do it you know implementation Lee
um lies on our live stream is osteons
associations supposed to be order less
the answer is they are order lists for
some purposes but not for others as a
courtesy they maintain their order for
purposes of display but they are order
lists for purposes of pattern matching
and so on but as a courtesy they they
simply maintain the order for displays
at a fair characterization for people
who know the internals I believe you can
also index them by position okay yes by
right they maintain these things but
they are not meaningful for most
operations operations working
associations they behave as if they had
yeah right okay but anyway but with
respect to this um okay so
tentatively Association transfers would
have a second argument which is level
specification just like transpose when
the thing isn't when the thing is too
ragged um the UM it it will
with missings as appropriate and we
might later on figure out a bunch of
choices for how those missings get
pruned ok let me make a comment ok so we
are we good with Association transpose
moving forward ok why does this not work
why don't we prune the nothing's I think
this is related to the fact that we want
Association to be complete well yeah but
I mean it doesn't the association of
evaluation anyway that's the first time
yeah so it when it was constructed it
could remove them perhaps we could do he
has to distinguish rule from brooding
light and not remove it exactly that's
exactly what I would do yeah that's
exactly what I would do let's explore
that possibility ok so that is
implementable yeah disgusting as you see
with him potentially it was mark
okay when went you ping him and see what
he says about it first okay great on to
the next item oh my gosh this is a head
exploding topic so so those are the
options that we discussed first so this
was the motivation we gave in the
previous meeting why
I'm now trying to remember what the
point of this says it's the main thing
was that because we want to convert
these query expressions into a normal
form that includes apply through play
through is head map so we want to find
that the best name for it right it will
be nice - okay so head nap again is a
list of functions to a single okay so
these
discussing the curried forms there is it
apply it's not apply is it it's not
apply but it's it's it's what it is is
its construct so right now if I say F G
X that's really wild what is that doing
if I do that I get that which is what we
would expect
I mean it's really obscure you know the
things like constructor cross it's
really quite obscure right combination
of power it's really obscure I mean you
have to tell to explain that joke you
have to give the whole history of the
world so to speak I mean it's just
i-it's very obscure all right what is
the easy way to explain what this is
going to do this is taking a list of
functions list apply listed none of
these themes seem like what about
something like function list F G this
function what about the list construct
I'm thinking of what we did for with
take list from take you know this is
really a bad sign I'm starting to forget
how these things work
yeah okay fine by six that's a
successive take her yeah that's what I
thought um I think constructors at an
obscure I mean constructor is an unusual
function anyway I don't think we should
compound it here and unfortunately the
meaning of function here is wrong
because function of f of X will give us
F
functions too general to be applied here
you know lies on our livestream is
asking what is this supposed to be how
will it work with pattern matching
I don't think it has a real story with
Latin matching because I don't think I
think this is a thing that the object
itself I mean the object itself is
analogous to something like one of these
function composition thingies right
where where I could then say of X why
doesn't that work although I have to do
here to make that work like that right
it's one of these things that is a it's
in that family it's something that
automatically takes a list of functions
and gives a list of results from that
list of functions did we write
documentation page for it so let's
say with whatever this thing is called
head map or whatever of FG well f1 f2
you know gives whatever it gives so
that's easy to explain by example yeah
it's so easy to explain this function by
example but we just need it to have a
name
I mean honestly with you all these names
head mappers is some the difficulty with
head map is it's not a map right well
except it is a map no I understand that
but it's a map into the head I'm
beginning to
think that head map is the least bad
yeah I mean in Genesis on a live stream
is suggesting list apply the problem is
it's not an apply it's really a
construct but it's a but in a sense it's
a map because it's a map against that I
think head map is the least bad that
we've come up with I think it's what we
should do okay word list yes so this is
something Shawn suggested but we've gone
over a couple of different times and
that's looking at functions like word
list and the way they interact with word
frequency data or other corpora for
frequency weighting of random words or
word list elements or being able to say
you know give me the 500 most frequently
used words in English or Spanish and
trying to figure out what subset of
those queries make sense to build in to
word list if we should just have you
know sorted by frequency be some sort of
method you can request or have that be
part of weird frequency data or if we
should curate a list of the thousand
most frequently used words at least
according to our corpora or some other
corpus so let's give a few comments so
first of all in word list we're already
having various options for what the word
list can be right are those already
installed the ones but for you know that
the the kind of say
for enth grade or whatever type type
stuff yeah Chris is finishing up a
packet update that does some additional
filtering there different parameters we
want to look at in terms of you know we
don't want to necessarily get into the
realm of censoring language but we want
to have you know if you give a random
word we don't want profanity showing up
is hey wrap it but what was the option
name that we came up with for that
I don't remember offhand let me see if
we can find that real quick okay but
that was that that's the thing we have
to concentrate on here right because
that's the we might be in the
documentation future I think that's for
search results but I think that that
would be um look we had it's interesting
it's not documented um I think we had
Allen and I had worked out a whole
scheme for this because there are
different levels of you know the issue
is whether you include Aiea the issue
also is it with random word okay so
random word for example also has this
question of does it deal with words
sorted according to frequency Ray and I
don't think we
this discussion very well without Alan
come of everything and see if Alan is
available sure yeah um and uh okay but I
I do agree that random would yeah I mean
that will be useful so random would
doing something proportional to word
usage is very similar to our sequence
predict functions that try and generate
things according to a language model am
I making sense yeah yeah really just
choosing a random word out of a
dictionary is only useful to a certain
degree having it well it's a different
it's a different use case I mean it's
like how many words do I know in English
okay let me take a sample of 20 that's
quite useful but um I agree there are
plenty of cases where you want to okay
so the case of random word yeah we've
already got known words and I think we
have a notion of communist common words
right yeah mm-hmm the exact definition
of that isn't super well laid out but we
basically have you know I think it ends
up being about the 40,000 most common
words in our dictionary yeah yeah yeah
right and so I don't know if it makes
sense to add additional filters like
very common words or if we just want to
have sort of those umbrella categories
and well I would think that we could do
something like random wood you know
you know we don't even document this
what the heck we don't even document
that case that's the most common case
made on a document that's just totally
wrong
yeah it should definitely be lit
embarrassingly wrong should be the
second use case it should can you add
that please yeah I'll do it
that's really embarrassing
because what I was thinking was that we
could have a thing which gives which
says pick my words only from the N most
common words
to get what I'm saying okay so look that
there's
all different cases we want okay so one
case one thing we want is um and I
should start to separate I mean this is
gonna end up being a longer discussion
here
did somebody consumer to determine if
Alan was available am I was trying to
reach out okay so the issue is okay so
the questions are you know how uncommon
do the other words allowed to be that's
case one and case two is are the words
weighted by their frequencies in the
language right it's a number of
suggestions on our livestream yeah so
the suggestion or suggestion on the
livestream astir is to wait by how
common okay so how uncommon of the words
allowed to be either by rank or by
frequency now I can imagine you know if
you're doing a spelling bee you want
words might want words less common than
a given thing mmm okay so what this is
suggesting is am I going here um why
should I put this
any thoughts on weather should go or do
I have to make a custom thing here I
don't think you have a text YouTube is
very bad feeling that I have to call
this some well I have an LP I'm gonna
put it under an LP yeah makes sense
um okay now let's think about an analogy
here with other random I mean so random
entity I mean that so the analogy here
so this is about random word and I mean
you know let me make a stupid suggestion
but random entity you know I could say
give me a random chemical element
weighted by the by the occurrence in the
Earth's crust which is kind of stupid
right yeah well I mean you know random
entity eg cities weighted by their
population it's not completely stupid
all right there are a number of useful
properties that one could weight by my
area or something like that right so
that me
that random Eric random entity so if it
is the case that other given words how
do we find out the frequency of a word
in English we say word frequency data
okay I'm Alan what did we figure out
about the not just profanity filter but
the you know suitable for middle school
type um filter for word list well what
we ended up doing was just reading a
bunch of some additional profanity and
other offensive words out of the default
common words list for right now we had a
design for something more nuanced and I
I have to find that design again it was
what we wanted to do is to have a list
of attributes that the words could have
or not right they were a profanity
sexual content drug reference I mean
they were they were all sorts of other
sort of fine-grained subcategories of
types of words that people might want to
filter right but the bottom line was our
criterion was given a classroom of
elementary school kids there was a
category of words that would should lead
to nono and tittering young kids perhaps
that that is something that a little bit
depends on you know on time but you know
that that's the goal for that correct
they're not and yeah not and I think
that we've done there with the latest
version so it it's not just words you
can't say on TV but also dick I think
things that things that might have a
might have a reasonable yeah but but we
but we agreed that words that have a
perfect lean on innuendo eyes meaning
would be left right because there's a
different case
which is you know do you disallow I
don't know gay or something right right
and it has a because it has a meaning
that could cause trouble but you it has
a perfectly reasonable meaning that is
not problematic at all it depends on
whether the whether the problematic
meeting is so much more overwhelmingly
common than the non problematic one I
understand I understand I know we also
had an idea of how to get something
where it where you could filter out all
words that have no unproblematic
meanings even if because remember for
random word it's just like okay if
you're picking a bunch of random words
it's okay you can just ignore the words
you know then there are enough words to
go around that you could just remove any
word that has a you know any substantial
problematic meaning if you want right
random word so what is our mechanism for
doing that
I'm not even sure what you're asking
that the last thing we talked about was
you wanted you wanted a random word
which just consults common word for word
list you wanted that list of common
words to remove anything that might
produce tittering in a in a boy wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
there are two categories of words there
are words whose meaning is predominantly
Tessa generating so to speak sure there
are words where the predominant meaning
is just fine but where there is a
possible meaning that is problematic
right and we need to distinguish those
cases because we don't want to blacklist
words where the overwhelming probability
is that they're being used in a
perfectly reasonable way sure right so
we didn't do that did we
we only removed words whose predominant
meaning is problematic correct yes okay
so there's a separate issue which is to
remove words whose you know one of whose
meanings is problematic am I making
sense somebody is making background
noise by the way yes sorry I've there
was me just checking something like I
was the word screw is still in word list
okay fine right so so then the issue is
um words with problematic meanings well
so the question is is the is the word
predominantly problem
tick or
just can be problematic right
I think that you know micro deciding
whether to include you know I don't know
drug related words or something is it's
just it's too difficult I think that
this is the criterion is it
predominantly problematic or it can be
problematic
so to speak that makes sense
all right I was yes now what's the
relationship to
the
um what's the relationship with dollar
allow allow allow adult content what
where are we using dollar that that I
think that was um introduced for and is
only being used for search results yeah
but why is this not even showing up as a
thing here is that a dollar variable or
is it a option in those functions ah
it's an option in those functions okay
we had we had talked at one point about
whether that should be a dollar variable
but had opted just to keep it in those
functions for the time being so we
didn't have more use cases that were
sufficiently clear to make that a more
general thing um we don't document it
hmm is it on those maybe just on those
pages
yes
I see and we don't document I see we're
oh boy we are engineering this in some
weird way because it isn't in the it
isn't in the search system right we
excluded it from the search system I
don't know well this is the right way to
do it
okay well but I think that the general
idea of a Lao adult content as an option
so so wait a minute if we do want to get
problematic words we get that if we go
to all known words that correct as
opposed to consulates okay that's
everything in the dictionary
you
so I could imagine that we could have a
lower adult content aro none
the UM could mean that we could have the
following settings that allow an adult
content of true means they of it just
allow any word right then to say false
would mean disallow predominantly
problematic words
you actually you've got it I'm not sure
where there's notebook is in your in
your tree but you've got a profanity -
oh one notebook where you had outlined
something and I think you had ended up
suggesting something that was a we
talked about adult content you ended up
something like avoided categories which
hold on hold on yeah because there are
other things which are I mean this is
such a kind of worms there are other
things which um um what was it called
profanity you said it was cool this
profanity - oh one I'm not oh yeah I'm
fine
I stole denotes word-lists okay hey how
we doing it getting all the Swadesh
lists and I was just having a meeting
with Ben about that we were just
organizing all the the remaining
curation stuff that needs to be done to
review those we have a bunch of language
word lists that we had just hit pause on
that months back because we didn't
possibly have the time or resources to
get things confidently cleaned for
twelve my some of that is back with the
curation yes with all this race oh my
gosh this is a horrible mess that's why
I think we decided not to
you
all right so well what are we doing with
this phone on our live stream is saying
don't remove algae bt words
this is a horrible mess I mean this is
kind of a microcosm of you know basis of
society so to speak put in our um
now maintaining those two problematic
words is labor-intensive Brian on
livestream comments yeah you don't say I
mean well you know unfortunately it's
one of these things that's driven by bad
things happening because you know there
are words that can I don't know what the
I don't know how quickly a word can
become problematic probably fairly
quickly probably within a month that
could become problematic what do you
think Ellen potentially I think I mean
it's it's hard to say when something can
something catches on that quickly
definitely things that are that are sort
of broadly thought of as okay ways to
refer to particular groups can quickly
become pejorative right lies on the live
stream is saying when you should look at
the auto mode settings on twitch I don't
know where those are but are those for
the for the text stream maybe somebody
could look at those and send me a screen
or something um I mean I don't know what
let's see I mean yeah they certainly
must come up in in text chats and I
don't know what in forums and things
like this um ah somebody okay
boy it requires me to log in and so on
but somebody send me a screenshot please
um
okay
so um let's come back to this okay so
look we've got several different things
here ah there we go okay this is our uh
item that work
to expected that to work weird weird
weird weird okay do you want it as an
email no I've got it okay notice Oh
oh my gosh hostility that's another can
of worms do they have a list of what
actual words they have I already know me
find out please um yeah anyway this
clearly not a
this sadly reminds me of countries where
sigh where you know which try to exclude
certain content on their own websites in
those countries and so on and where in
the end it turns into this weird
spreadsheet of these are things we think
we're disallowing and so on um it's
pretty it's yeah well this gets to be um
it's not unrelated to what I'm supposed
to be thinking about for that um Senate
testimony that I um involved in the okay
um let's see so okay so where are we
going with this
okay first question is what do we want
to do yeah I mean this is this is a big
can of worms - it's probably as
problematic -
um you know it's as plausible
like to give these lists of words as it
is to exclude them in some places Allen
adds some sensibleness to this I guess
the thing that I'm thinking about it is
that the more that we look at these
we're focused on a very specific subset
of words and trying to categorize them
and I because they're they're
problematic I don't is it problematic to
have to flag a set of words as being
related to sexuality
if we also had groups of lists that were
related to food or travel or
transportation or other things I mean if
these categories are just certain you
know it's it's hard because we're we're
focused on this very small subset of
things but maybe what would be more
useful is topic based war or topic based
things yes
could we do that from the network of
words that we have in the I think I
think between between word data and
concept data since that's you know
that's just an inversion of word net and
we can we can fill in the blanks and
hook things up for all the rest of the
words that we've added in I think if
it's possible this is the same kind of
worms as topic modeling and you know
what we've discussed before about you
know what are the target topics like
there are those target topics we used
ages ago the face book study but those
are clearly not general and we think you
know we thought about using Library of
Congress ones or using whatever but I
mean do we think are we going to get
ourselves in the same tangle there I
mean one possibility is to simply say
okay so let's take virtuous okay let's
take the word virtuous which is probably
in the same category as heroic but let's
take that word and let's say we say word
data of that word and we say hypernym
right or what would we call it and we
call it some broader broader to utter
terms right
okay so this is should give us that's
not useful that's very not useful
great those those word sense
disambiguation czar okay well let's see
whether um is that going to give us and
see this is broader term isn't gonna be
useful because that's not that's not
giving us
that's giving us a word meaning broader
term not a super category in the sense
that you would find in a section of a
thesaurus or whatever farriner now do we
have that in the concept hierarchy maybe
we do that's what I'm looking for right
now yeah but I mean the concept
hierarchy I don't think is going to
involve you know virtue I don't think
the adjectives are going to be in the
concept hierarchy that we have because
that's a noun based concept hierarchy
for things like image identification
yeah maybe we don't take that but you
know look I mean Roget's thesaurus for
example had super categories and it
seems like everybody
poor mr. Roche um dr. Roger I think he
was um I think it was a medical doctor
the you know an awful lot of people have
used his kind of um
you know way of bucketing things into
super categories I wonder if we I mean I
don't know we have them right isn't
Barbara Cooper's version of that thing I
wonder if she kept the same categories
or not um but it's the you know what I'm
talking about Allen at the end of the
thesaurus there's a you know like I'm
looking through one here there's causes
fields of human activity right yeah I
mean so this does have a categorization
health legal whatever there is a
perfectly you know there's a I think
some of them are a bit funky here oh
great this is funny so there's a there's
a section called um life forms that's
got beings and things like that and
that's got a section called general
characteristics and it's page after page
of things here that include terms like
choosy and boorish which I guess
but probably didn't manage to figure out
now I wonder whether that comes from
Roche in the original or whether that
was her her redoing of Roche um okay so
there's sections here that are much
shorter like Natural Resources is rather
short a bit odd actually if you ask me
um yeah I mean so this is well okay so
that I mean clearly okay so I mean if we
pick here words do we have reduced the
Souris in the in the data repository do
you know you know I don't think so we
certainly could it's way out of
copyright the odds yes we should
probably get it in there we could
probably get it in there as an entity
store with them let's see oh look at
that that's cool as I remember that this
this thing is some
I don't know what this would look like
let's try our virtuous word egg this is
a very old website whatever it is
what happens if I do that
who knows so somebody had a hyperbolic
tree visualization of the thing but
anyway that there's got to be raw data
from somewhere where we can just get the
arts take a look here um oh yeah we had
we had a bunch of these things
plain text utf-8 right it's what we
would probably want
and I see what is this what on earth is
that word turkey versus Asian late well
the language has changed a bit um that's
a great word it is a great word yeah um
equivocation basically Sal rota means to
achieve a search and I wonder whether we
have that would I wonder whether that's
a dictionary word for us um by the way
is dictionary word cue doing yes did I
spell it right it's in word data oh so I
just spelled it wrong wait a minute why
isn't it in dictionary word cue is Nick
here yes I know that er that's is that
yeah we're working I mean that that part
is just waiting on Francisco to
double-check and make sure there's no
other concerns but there's still the the
general project that I know Ben was
coordinating to unify all the
dictionaries because dictionary word cue
and spelling correction list used the
same dictionaries that the spell
checking system that the front end uses
and word data it pulls from different
dictionaries and trying to get those all
unified was kind of an epic project that
Ben was coordinating at least at one
point I know well is that is that gonna
get done my understanding was it was I
haven't been following because I've been
tied ups with some other things but why
I still don't understand why dictionary
word queue wouldn't recognize well
doesn't word if we don't yeah it's
spelled right why isn't why isn't that
recognized by dictionary word queue if
it's in
we're data I mean I know there's there's
a separate problem of we have we've
added things to the spelling
dictionaries that we haven't added but
what worries for in word I just got the
spelled wrong is this just spelled wrong
is it not a common word because weird
list open/close is common words it's not
a common word in my yeah okay so we're
good yeah it's not a common would but it
is a would right we're good
but dictionary would q should be against
known words right so dictionary word q
is what was originally going to be
called spelled correctly q it ties into
the spelling correction system and I
think the false positive here but the
false negative here is that the
Supplemental dictionary that it needs to
be checking for things that we've added
from word list isn't getting loaded here
which is something I'm in the process of
fixing I just need so is it the case
that the woods that we're adding into
the spelling list which no I add them
practically daily mm-hmm that's the
thing that Nick is saying we have not
universally added those as new entries
in work data itself oh yeah but touch of
Accession ok fine but but let me make a
comment that for example I don't know
where the midplane which was a word that
I just added you know a few days ago it
is midplane a common word I don't really
think so right or or the word I
understand or seven probably not a
common word but so it should be in Owen
words but not in common words right but
on the other hand there's other things
that I'm adding I this actually in
midplane is inward data so I wonder if
we've been adding things to the well
we've made an ad in certain areas
because it because of the bug that Nick
just mentioned there are things that
should have been showing at this felt
correctly well but there are plenty of
things which are modern words that are
not in the dictionary but they are
fairly common modern words which we're
adding two spellings and which should
get added to common words in word list
right right but that's that's the
separate synchronization project I mean
I think we were at a point where we
should go in and we should we can do a
diff of things that are okay but the
point that I'm making
I don't okay the point I make
is that that we're gonna have to split
the spelling words into words which
should be in knowing words and words it
should be in common words sure okay
now in terms of the the word categories
I kind of agree I think it's an
interesting thing to do I think we
should make I think we should try it
based on oh boy I mean the bags of words
that we get in the topic model oh we
must have some of those from even the
project that we did what how many years
ago it was on the Facebook post topics
right yeah um okay all right so let's
come back to the original question so
the original question was didn't we have
a didn't we have a notion of communist
words that was supposed to be a thing
that we could ask for a given piece of
text actually didn't we have a communist
words thing that we were planning for a
long time for even foot four um hold on
let me look you want something right to
look up basically onward frequency data
make me not comment on why that was that
was gonna require some reworking of the
the engrams database
okay but but but do you agree that that
was a thing that we were talking it was
it is a thing we have talked about okay
me see if I have notes about it I see
something in your low-hanging notebook
yeah so do I here we go um so this is
you
okay so this is what we had in mind
it seems to have been a lower priority
in 2017 which is perhaps why we're now
in 2019 it still hasn't been done but
then we had the idea of common words
common words ranked
perhaps the in argument can be just rank
I mean this would effectively be the
same thing as word count or word counts
no no this is with respect to a corpus
whether they're okay with a corpus I see
I mean this is a different thing and I
agree that this does this is this is
just the the list it's currently
returned by a word list but sorted
exactly ranked in some way yeah so the
question is then one possibility would
be to have um well I don't even know
yeah okay so one possibility is word
list which currently is alphabetical to
say common words ranked and have that be
returning list of words in order of
frequency
yeah which will be just one computation
from from word frequency data right yep
and we can always pre compute that we
absolutely should recompute
it's gonna be a long computation so
let's do it
I mean that one seems useful own words
ranked do we want to include I mean
under the hood we can certainly include
the frequencies also which gives us the
ability to do weighting and random word
but do we want an exposed version or
just I don't know a common common words
ranked with frequency is kind of a long
well yeah but it's question what does it
return does it return what it really
should return would be an association of
the type that would be used by a random
choice right because if what this
returned
I mean if we weren't basically something
that looks like the output of word
frequency data but just where it goes to
whatever the frequency measurement is
well a better way to do this then would
be okay so then this is one thing is
common word with ranked but then what we
could do is word frequency data of all
could generate that Association
matic or something could generate that
association
you
right so this case here you know
fundamentally what you're saying is that
this thing is equivalent to word
frequency data of word list right that's
that's um that makes sense
yeah sorry so are you saying that word
frequency data all would be everything
in wordlist not not everything from the
Ingram's database that's what I was
thinking because there's lots about it
as it there's a long tail of yeah Goong
junk right but I mean I think it would
be most natural would be to say
I don't know
we'll be the common words thing yeah the
second argument would get tricky if you
asked for time series of all words
that'd be a pretty big data set but the
single our case is pretty
straightforward yes that would be
ridiculous
okay but the issue is
what's the second argument of word list
oh it doesn't have one yeah we just have
the different types right now
well what about the possibility that
word list of n
gives you the N communist words
not bad yeah and then if you give a type
it gives you the end communist words of
the specified type that seems reasonable
and what do we do if we say word list of
ten to the six I think it prints a
message and then returns everything it
has does that seem reasonable because in
a given language different languages you
might actually have different you know a
given gulp size would work differently
so for example if you do it for you know
some totally obscure you know language
spoken by five people for which we only
have a Swadesh list of you know 30 words
or something then asking for a million
words or even 10,000 words and that
language will fail so I think we would
generate a message and then just give
everything we have in that case mm-hmm
yeah and I think there are a handful of
languages that we have word lists for
but we don't have frequency data for so
we'll just in that case handle it the
same way of just saying there's an
frequency data associated with it right
I mean we could in fact easily derive
frequency data by just by just doing
that ourselves on a small corpus yeah
because even the language is where we
don't have very many words we'll also be
able to pick up I mean I don't know can
you give an example of such a language I
think if I remember right we have what
like ten languages and the Ingram's yeah
no and I understand that but I mean what
we could do for the other languages it
really is not a difficult project to go
and animate almost want to make me add
it to the summer school list of that to
derive would frequency data for obscure
languages I think we should add that to
the summer school list somebody could
could dumb yeah yeah we don't have a
word frequency fritz Hamel or okay I
mean it's also a question of inflections
for some of these languages which could
get really weird mm-hm
um Brian on livestream is pointing out
that the online slang dictionary offers
words by topic and crowd sources to
determine offensiveness it's an
interesting claim oh wow look at look at
all those things it's quite a list of
trackers it really is
so I wonder what oh boy
you
so do they have wordlist
I see do we have any of the stages this
data I don't know whether that's that
what the licensing this is um
you
you
Africanness sake what a mess what a mess
okay
um
against the site oh my gosh what a mess
great well that's fascinating
for other reasons but what a mess um
okay anyway
um so what was the
the point was the claim was that this
has a crowdsourcing to determine
offensiveness interesting I mean that
might be an interesting basis to use I
suppose anybody want to comment on that
I don't know anybody else I'm sorry I
say I was I was just looking something
else on a site - what was their question
the point was that apparently they have
a crowdsourced
I mean this that's another can of worms
I mean what does what a you know oh my
gosh
um okay well anyway this is this is a
horrible can of worms we're not gonna
solve this I think all we can do is
we're removing from okay so four random
words
we probably need an option to not
generate titter generating words and I
don't know how to deal with that
and I think that the most plausible way
to do it so that it won't get broken is
to have a dollar allow adult content or
something and set it to none because if
one I mean
actual practical uses of this it's got
to be set in some initialization way
you
yeah dude um okay we clearly this is a
let's we have to get off this topic but
we're gonna have to come back to this
topic because we're not
this isn't um let's say disallow okay
all right it's the only thing else we
need to do right now here I mean this
question about random word I think we
should not go in the random word
weighted by frequency
unfortunately this scheme of the enth
most common word doesn't give us I mean
it would also be interesting if we could
say word list you know something like
[Music]
you know something along the lines of
frequency threshold
and give up there so that if you're
interested in more rare awards you can
say from 1,000 to 2,000 yeah yeah yeah
but I mean also if you want words whose
frequency is less than one in ten to the
six for example don't we have in machine
learning functions don't we have that
notion
um
no that's something different we have a
[Music]
this notion
of well I think we should ask the
machine man in folk I think we already
have a notion that would be suitable to
use for this
I mean there is kind of a CDF notion of
all of a word
yeah anyway but but I think this is a
nice thing to try so common words ranked
and wordless to the N I think we should
try that to begin with and then word
frequency data of all or automatic
generating this giant Association
hello makes sense to me
okay well so we look now on to some
completely other topics which perhaps we
shouldn't try to tackle today since
we're over time um oh well not actually
we do have a couple more minutes I at
least have a couple more minutes here um
are we able to let's see so I think I'm
a bit disappointed that we have to again
abandon I mean so so okay so the one
remaining thing would be a word list by
topic right and as Alan is suggesting
the word list by topic
could have an excluded topics area you
know we could exclude sir just as we
include certain topics in word list we
could exclude certain topics but again
that's a big can of worms because
ocean of a word in a topic list
yeah we did that would say if you
exclude a topic like I don't know
profanity or something then
yeah yeah no no help this is a mess
I mean language quickly overlaps with
speech and trying to filter either of
them are pretty complicated and tricky
things but yeah if you want to say
exclude profane words do you want to
exclude exclusively profane words or
anything that has a profane tag yeah
yeah I know I know I know I know that's
the sameness
well it's also doesn't help that you
know in in the imperfection of human
language as opposed to computational
language a single word can have multiple
meanings right I wonder if there's any
human language in which that's not the
case
I suspect it's impossible because the
evolution of human language will be is
such that a word gets kind of from sort
of trained well also also are there
languages like Icelandic that don't want
to create new words that reuse them I
think so I think that's that that's why
and I think it's in that language that
term the word for computer is based on
something like you know sorceress of
numbers something like that I believe
because they don't want to create an
actual new you know actual form um now
I'm now I'm now that that is going to
lead me to to just try I think it's
something really obscure that doesn't
have any kind of root oops
you
we really have Icelandic soldiers yeah I
thought that's what it was very weird
word for computer although how exactly
that pack sorceress of numbers into into
that single word I don't really have any
idea um okay
a mystery alright okay let's change
topics which means um what wait a second
so the one trailing issue is the topics
based word lists and Allen are we going
to you know that there will be a good
thing that's another good summer school
topic you know that's a good summer
school project is to try and make some
topic word lists um here we can we can
do some scouting around look at
different sources to try and build those
up I'm actually I'm have to say I'm I'm
just going to add this to my am
ah my nice organized um list of projects
for the year um humph
let's see I think they already sent them
outside gotta add these okay so this is
word lists for more obscure languages
and um topic word lists by for specific
topics okay alright alright so Alan I
think that's some yeah someone's asking
about if quelle here yes I recently met
the creator of ethic well fascinating um
I don't think if quill has the feature
that I don't know if it allows I think
it you may be right that it doesn't
allow ambiguity that every word in a
squirrel has a unique meaning um so it's
fascinating language which I hope to
study more even though its creator can't
speak it but that's because it's the
world's most complicated constructed
language um and it's has a lot of exotic
stuff in it
it also has exotic letter forms and
things which is just adding to the the
weirdness and not necessary for the
concept um
okay we're gonna change topics and very
quickly try and go through these other
things here so I don't if I think we're
we're done briefings for you thanks a
lot bye okay ragged dimensions so the
idea here is to quickly get a report on
the structure of the shape we are
interested in the data set is going to
be eating so this is an extension of the
language of dimensions to things that
are rugged and have here we are the
examples and the way what the heck is
this ragged thing what is that what does
it mean right so it means would you have
a list which is rugged and inside the
first element ISM is a matrix of two to
the second element is a matrix of two
one the third is Sasuke so by doing
these we can report the structure of
ragged things I'm confused by this I'm
sorry this is this is what is ragged
here is ragged a symbolic object yes so
this is just a temporary suggestion for
how to represent these but yes you went
to the most complicated example so yes
these simple example here will okay so
these are all dense I mean these are all
full things okay so now this is the
first case where rags out so to speak
exactly
so it just reports the dimensions of the
things it has inside
it's a list of two elements the first
one is a length to listen nicely so you
can nest these things so if I drag if I
for example let's imagine that I rag if
I here so this is a full language and
there is a function called example array
that goes the other way giving a ragged
dimensions representation it gives you
an example I have to say these seem like
quintessential function repository
functions like example array seems
useful but only okay but you're saying
that you think that this thing with
ragged so what about sparse array could
it be given a ragged specification like
this and generate a ragged sparse array
well you say that but but why well
person of sparse arrays always assumes
for clarity for example you cannot you
cannot feed an element of a special rate
which is an array itself so by
construction it will always return arise
I see but you could imagine a sparse
array construct that would eat ragged
specifications right okay but the main
point here is is that when it eats
arbitrary data it has to quickly make
decisions from the shape of the
representation so because now it spends
time also analyzing the types of things
we won't first something which very
quickly only looks as a structure at a
structure and therefore it so I agree
that this is useful um I'm a little
concerned about this ragged head which
seems like a bit a you know unless it's
gonna be supporting a lot of places it
seems like kind of a crazy thing to have
and I wonder how we can package that
without that
I mean possibly we can just use lists
nested lists
I can relate obscure but that it's going
to be difficult to read but I want to
discuss first with you the idea itself
of how this works I know this is a
general language what's that well it
seems I mean the only issue is what is
the best okay so the simplest case is a
single number represents the contiguous
yeah what what does this really mean
so a single number if I take this
example up here you know a single number
like 2 2 I mean if I ever let me let me
just do the a case here where we okay so
2 3 means the first 2 there means
there's two things and there's no
raggedness to the whole thing the 2
means 2 elements whose structure is 3
and then you go deeper why does this go
the other way around I see so wait a
minute why isn't that so write a list so
right it is same I have a vector of 3
and a vector of 2 rocket corresponds to
a single level reporting the dimensions
of the things it has inside right but so
ragged of 3 comma 3 is equivalent to 3
to 3 it's two elements actually evaluate
that evaluates ragged of two three three
it's two elements each one having
dimensions three
I see but if you have three four then it
cannot no I understand but but so the
point here is that what degenerates into
that - I feel like there's some thing in
which this is sort of an there's some
analogy here between something which is
the pure - and something which is
composed I mean what is this - go ahead
what see so for example if you put these
in at least with another rocket or a
number after it you see the power of
this combination so what do you mean of
so if I'm saying this come up what does
it deal with that case so look what it
did ah ah look what this did because
this in fact reveals a bit of a problem
right because this in fact should turn
into you know a sequence two three four
of exemplary itself so should change the
three three two or three two for example
so the point here is that we have a
rugged array whose elements are actually
all of the same dimensions and so the
idea of the tensor Pro
product of the tensor product here still
applicable so all the deeper elements of
this array are still of dimension 4
what what's the 10 surprise
got to do with it yes I see that when
you add when you put in that four thing
what you're essentially doing is like
tensor product in something it's like
adding an extra index and the I
understand so I have to ask the kind of
general turistic like question here
which is is there an analog of this
ragged thing in standard tensor index
manipulation I don't think so because in
the standard language would you always
assume reality you may have different
dimensions you may have indices
belonging to different spaces and they
have different dimensions right but I
mean in the case of okay so what you're
saying here is the ragged let's see I'm
still slightly confused I'm still
there's something I think I'm missing
here um in terms of a way to think about
this you know this is so like splitting
I understand that I understand that I
mean I understand you want this
functionality and there's no problem I
mean the question is can there be a
built-in function that is nicely user
accessible right so there are questions
sometimes of how do I get data set to
typeset in this way and the only way to
do it is is to provide yourself these
type of information right now with the
data system so you're the point that
you're making is that this specification
would be something you could actually
feed to data set this ragged 3 3 4 etc
etc right if you're interested in it get
in it some shape
hmm okay well I mean I don't know how
generally have we thought about how
generally in the system this stuff would
have to be supported like it's a shame
that sparse array couldn't take one of
these well because in special raid you
always have the element there is there's
not much problem in just analyzing what
happens in sparse array if the default
element is nothing I see if you to do
normal then it would disappear so if I
say sparse array one arrow a five arrow
B and then the default element is
nothing I just say six okay the weird
color there which makes me very
suspicious oh cool
the nothing goes away then so but but if
I then were to say in the sparse array
hmm okay so in principle I mean just for
the sake of understanding what's going
on we could allow the ragged
specification to go into that second
element of sparse array padding with
nothing's yeah I think it will but not
if it was padded with nothing's I don't
know no I see what you're saying I see
what you're saying you can't have a
different depth of lists
what is it you want to do here so I just
wanted to present this idea to see first
the reaction and whether you had some
suggestion of how to modify or or the
name right it yes I mean I'm a hobby
with rugged but for me it's to develop
this it's easier to see it rather than
lists no I agree I think let's earn a
mess um I also just don't know about all
the other places that should appear and
I suspect there are a bunch there's no
obligation for the functions to support
this but we have it yeah and it's very
fast in analyzing large expressions then
this can become useful mm-hmm for
example your position I have a similar
problem because polygons also contain
ragged lists of positions and that was
example that is there at the end so they
are that polygon it's described in both
the ragged structure of the lists and
then at the entries are - meaning they
are yeah I understand that's nice
why do you put the sub lists inside the
ragged numbers yeah I mean it could
canonicalize to just a sequence of
numbers not a sub list here so you have
a list of matrices of different
dimensions I see I see if one of them is
a matrix and one of them is just a
single one dimensional list yeah okay uh
what would you call us them
I mean in a sense it's not this that is
ragged adjust the things below it but
well gosh list containing objects it
could be rocket list it's not a list
I mean honestly things like cyclic that
we happen to have as specifications as
small explosive equations are fairly
similar to this ragged concept here
cyclic tuning cycles cycles yes psychos
presentation of the full object not so
much about its structure I see I mean in
a sense this thing is ragged dimensions
except using ragged dimensions is the
thing to generate this I'm not sure but
I think I agree that the idea of this is
perfectly reasonable I think the answer
of this is probably yes latest cameras
by the way um yeah we're going to see
what to do with groupings the previous
cases right um all right well that this
is probably a big mess right I mean if
you do this some
yeah you generate that and then you say
ragged dimensions of that it's a giant
structure isn't it yes it's going to be
similarly large yeah but then yes if we
group them or we sort them like in the
previous case so this is like the
missions it's looking for repeatedly
structure if there is repeated I mean
it's not obvious to me that ragged
dimensions is quite right because you're
asking for yeah I mean you're trying to
match up which things are sort of a
places where there is corresponding
structure in different leaves and this
rag
is the case where the leaves don't
conform I mean it's it's a list of
lengths no a list of dimensions so no go
ahead an extension of the spec so Dena
spec is now a list of numbers now it
will be a list of numbers or bracket
objects yeah but on the tons of
functions that use team specs
yes I'm not suggesting that we
generalize all the Institute to rugged
cases I'm just saying that we have a
separate function that can report the
structure and then some functions can
use that I understand what's the
inventory of functions that could
conceivably use it well for the moment -
I'm working with are the geo position
heads and your vectors etc and but what
else has Adams back all the functions
taking the specs oh yeah oh gosh yes in
fact that's your example array would
just be so in particular the way that
would look is random integer you know 10
or something and that would essentially
fragment this would make
a deeper there's no point in it being
ragged if there's only if it isn't gonna
go deeper there's no reason for it to be
ragged so to speak well okay so what
does this mean so this means yes that go
ahead yes you have four lists of pairs
each one containing a list of length 5
Finale mm-hmm it would have depth 3
double 3 mm-hmm so racket is adding a
level of listing right so again to
understand what this is like ragged when
it degenerates becomes just its length
so you're saying well not 6 6 it becomes
2 comma 6 it will become 2 6 7 what are
you saying 6 7 comma 6 2 2 2 matrices it
would be a ragged list oh sure yeah that
would become 2 6 7 6 7 it's a list of 2
elements each of 1 its matrix 6 7
why did my Colonel just quit
I was doing nothing here what is
happening that's really weird
this maybe I might maybe running a
prototype build but I'm not saying we
should propagate these too many places
it's more the other way having this
function being used by some functions of
Caronia would benefit I understand but
but in the future we would end up
propagating it I suspect right time I'm
still just trying to understand its name
because I'm trying to understand what
this really means that this is a
dimension specification what's really
weird but there's an analogy and I'm
just not remembering what it is that
there are cases where you either give a
list of indices or you give the length
of the list where do we have examples of
that we've had other cases where you can
do that okay that's a depth effectively
look I don't object to the structure I
think I think the name ragged is is
weird
I'm still thinking here what is this
this is like it
like a dimensions list or something
because it's this is a list of
sub-dimension x' of things contained
here I'm not thrilled with that name but
it's I mean does that make any sense to
you it's no I understand that but I mean
by sang dimensions list we're giving the
idea that these are themselves
dimensions although dimensions this
could be something that returns
something but I think it can also be um
I mean oh of course the thing that we
are that's horrible
we don't use that anywhere we don't use
that kind of thing anywhere I think
dimensions list is my current favorite
though I'm not totally thrilled with it
Sadler is suggesting um ragged
specification or raggedness I know think
it's it's it's ragged they see I think
it's not a specification of raggedness
it's a specification of dimensions that
happen to be ragged
yeah I agree and Genesis on our
livestream is pointing out that
dimensions list suggests it gives the
list of dimensions huh I agree with that
problem hence dimension object well what
other non generator forms I think it's
very weird if we said something like
dimensions array because that's like
that's horrifying
that's too too much of a confusion with
array dimensions
I mean um by the way Ally on our
livestream mentions there was a ragged
partitions being discussed for a while
this is a different form okay take list
okay hold on hold on hold on so your
point is that take list if ice say take
list of you know some alphabets and then
I say four three two what has happened
to my kernel here okay so that is an
example of an implicitly ragged
specification intake list right yes so
in principle that will be equivalent to
ragged of list for list three list - yes
I was just pointing out that the
function that we were calling ragged
partition is finally called exists I
understand but that also reveals for us
look is a very close connection between
ragged dimensions and take list yes
and we should that's I mean I'm not
keeping this notebook so um
whoever's what oh yeah hmm so whatever
decorator there is for this thing all
right in modern times there's another
possible decorator that we could use
maybe it's crazy
instead of ragged we could have
something that is some symbol arrow
let's say 4 3 2 yeah I'm not sure this
is a good idea I mean I don't I don't
see any particular um yeah there's
nothing particularly if we generalize
these to report the head that's
interesting so what about associations I
mean why couldn't Ragged dimensions also
report on keys in an association but but
then then instead of a 4 here that will
be a list of keys actually I would like
to comment that isn't there an identity
between you know one thing is a list of
indices so there is an element that has
you know indices 1 2 3 4 that is
equivalent to just a straight four
specification right so that's the list
of indices form as opposed to the sub n'
subtree form which is what Raggett is
doing okay so there are different things
here there's list of indices there's
list of sub dimensions by the way that's
another phrase sub dimensions not sure I
like it very much but um I'm not sure I
like that but that's so I mean that the
possible things are list of indices
lists list of explicit of indices or
keys then there's a list of
sub-dimension x' and then there's just
size of this dimension correct and that
will be things like four there will be
things like one two three and sub
dimensions here would be in this case I
believe it would simply be one well it's
not even dimension one it would be a no
list right not that this is that case
sorry if I turn that into a three those
three are equivalent
so those first two are a little awkward
well I mean no I see you're saying that
this list of sub-dimension thing would
be could be ragged of the sublists well
actually it converts to three with a
brace which is a little weird well yes
because it's yes this is the issue we
were having before but these rugged of
empty lists represents a list of three
scalars correct so the dimensions of a
list of scalars is history oh you right
because raggedy said the mention suspect
not a length expect fair enough fair
enough
but okay but all three of these levels
need to be supported right so we need in
the case of keys here we would need to
be able to say Sandra is asking could
you use this classification in take to
get a ragged array out see that's
exactly the kind of issue that I was
thinking about here of you know in other
words that's like the cookie cutter
cutting out a piece of the array but
it's ragged I don't see why that
work if we have a specification like
this take takes specs at different
levels and not a single speck consider I
understand buddy in each at each level
oh I see you couldn't give a ragged okay
so that's more complicated so as an
issue that as the there is a extract as
to part as something is to take right is
the one article nature of take well for
example our a shape a shape well
actually array itself you know it's a
quintessential thing that could take a
raggedness specification so I think one
of the things we're learning here is
there are in fact quite a lot of
functions that could eat this ragged
specification if we allowed them to and
for example array right now can't work
on an association can it it can't work
on a list of keys that would be
Association array right but this kind of
specification would allow you to do that
directly inside array yes I need to run
along to something else here but but um
okay so the this this thing is a bit of
a deeper issue than we thought um I
think in terms of what you have here I
mean implementing this in however you
want internally you know exposing it
through function repository or whatever
seems just fine to me um but we should
come back to this again and try to
inventory what other functions that can
take it and then how to think about you
know I'm gonna send you back this some
this notebook because I'm worried that
I'm gonna lose it otherwise unless I put
in a specific place um okay um so um
yeah all right
um okay well yeah I mean we really need
something where we can get all three of
these levels of specification right
because this is the analog in table here
this is the analog of table across
certain kinds of things right yes and we
could imagine a ragged specification for
table could we not have the steak it
works oh yeah I see what you're saying
it's a barrel thing exactly what you
said parties bark extract is not so
right okay well very interesting um
sander is asking whether you could have
ragged as one piece the problem is that
ragged is a forward-looking creature I'm
not mistaken so in other words if I have
Sanders example here I don't think that
quite works because that's asking for a
that is equivalent to if I degenerated
this to five five for example right
right that's asking that is a
forward-looking thing which would really
be the equivalent of two five needs to
be splice into two yeah well okay that
reveals another possibility that we have
a wrapper which essentially D verifies
those arguments for both table and take
in other words a multi-level a thing
which packages up you get what I'm
saying no I know it might be wrong I
mean I'm just throwing that out there as
a possible way to do this see the thing
about it is that you know this is
sounding like the beginnings of a sort
of generalized dimensions wrapper which
could as a particular case support this
ragged thing but also support the you
know individual keys and other things
like that all right I have to go um I
noticed that on the calendar there's a
function repository discussion I don't
know if we're live-streaming that or not
um well we'll find out later